各位同學大家好,我是螞蟻秘書人環群山,下面由我來為大家介紹密台計算的地圖,密台交囊技術。
今天我會從密台交囊、密台交囊的測試,以及密台交囊的關鍵過程等方面進行展開。
我們來看一下密台交囊的定義與組成。
密台交囊是一種面向數據治理的分鑽機制。
它通過將數據內容與其數據使用控制策略緊密版訂,形成了一個不可分割自包含的治理單元。
該機制支持數據在不同系統或管理域之間安全留著,並確保在各目標環境中能夠被正確地解析和執行。
從而保障數據在全生命周期內的可控訪問與合規使用。
那麼我們如何通過數據分鑽來確保數據內容與使用控制策略緊密版訂的呢?
下面就讓我為大家介紹一下密台交囊的組成。
密台交囊它是由原數據、數據的密文、安全信息與使用控制策略組成。
為了確保消息的真實性、完整性和不可創改性、不可否認性,
它還使用了數字的簽名技術。
原數據是描述密台交囊的基本信息,包括數據的唯一標識,
使用著銷類型、表結構、數據占要、數據學員等信息。
數據的使用控制策略是保障密台交囊安全流轉的核心,
它包括了策略的配置以及規則列表的其中。
策略配置主要要來描述規則衝突時候的優先及決策,
每條規則會包括規則的授權量與備授權能,
效果生效週期操作約束等等。
為了確保密台交囊原始數據的安全,
我們採用了數據密藥DK來對明文的數據進行加密。
數據密藥DK本身經過另外一把KEK公要進行加密,
解鎖交囊的持有著信息,
這些就構成了密台交囊的安全信息的主要內容。
語言數據、使用控制策略、安全信息以及數據密穩整體,
構成了完整的密台交囊。
我們來看一下密台交囊與密台計算數字合約技術的關係。
密台交囊是密台計算底座的技術之一,
它依賴於密台計算的可信記者能力,
比如可信密藥服務TKMS等為密台交囊技術的實現提供了技術的能力。
下面我們來看一下密台交囊與數字合約的關係。
核心數據空間數字合約技術以數字化的形式明確約定數據提供方、
使用方、無方等相關槍雨方在數據使用環節中的權利和誘,
通過結構化的策略形式被數據的使用、用途、房地等要求進行了詳細的規定,
確保數據的使用過程及結果符合預期,
並且與數據控制技術協同實現的數據的可信的使用。
而密台交囊是一種以技術可信的方式,
實現了可信數據空間數字合約策略的方案。
它專注於數字合約策略的穿件與旅行的保障。
所以確保原始數據和延伸數據都受到原始數據提供方的策略管控,
確保以技術可信的方式實現數據的安全流轉。
我們來看一下密台交囊的技術特色。
密台交囊有兩大技術的特色。
一,基於數據使用空間的互聯互通。
首先,我們談一下基於數據使用的數據控制。
透過構建完整的數據使用圖,
我們去追蹤數據從採集、處理、貢獻到銷匯的全過程,
從而保證了數據提供方在數據流轉過程中的持續控制的權利,
支持數據安全的實現。
然後就跨空間的互聯互通,
支持密台交囊在不同的計算與存取與安全之間安全流轉,
從而實現了數據不動、計算動、策略水行的跨域協同能力。
下面我們介紹一下密台交囊的全線模型。
到底遊戲,也就是基於數據學員的使用控制。
它是基於數據學員關係的動態使用控制模型,
核心思想是將數據的使用權限與數據的學員跟主線,
也就是原始數據提供方進行本定,
通過學員入境的自動計程例子,
首先對數據集齊原生數據的全生命週期的權限管控。
我們的權限模型是為了達到如下積電保障,
依數據持有權保障,確保原始數據提供方對數據集齊原生數據的持續控制權,
支持數據快速流轉產品中的三權管控的實現。
而權限一致性保障,
通過學員入境的自動計程例子,
保證數據在話語流展中權限策略的一致性與可追溯性,
避免策略衝突或丟失。
協助安全性保障,
在多方數據餐廳中支持細力度權限管理,
平衡數據貢獻需求與原始數據提供方的控制需求,
使核規性保障,
滿足數據安全法規對數據使用入境的審計要求,
支持數據寬定流動限制,
生命週期約束等可規性的規則。
我們的權限模型,
有樓下核心的特性,
基於學員驅動,
權限決策依據數據來源之一流動入境,
而非用戶的身份服飾性。
學員跟逐線主導,
原始數據提供方對數據的使用範圍機,
擁有最終的控制權。
三,權限的動態繼承,
權限隨學員入境自動傳遞,
確保流漲過程度的權限一致性,
支持多元協同,
融合多元數據時,
允許滿足所有學員跟逐線的權限約束,
以右邊這張圖為例子,
用戶A提供了原始的數據,
第一,用戶B提供了原始的數據,
第二,用戶C,
它在獲得了數據第一和第二,
對你的提供方的授權之後,
通過提交任務,
它是可以生成了衍生數據的第三。
這裡要說明的是,
如果用戶C它沒有拿到
所有的交男學員跟逐線的授權,
那麼它就沒有權限自行相關的加工的任務。
後續,
其他的用戶想要加工,
或者使用衍生數據第三,
比如圖利的用戶第一,
它仍然受到了
學員跟逐線第一和第二對應的持有了限制。
我們採用了學員驅動策略,
由學員跟逐線主導
通過全線的動態繼承
來保障原始數據提供方對數據
及其衍生數據的持續空的權。
我們來講一下
兩種不同模式的跨空間的互聯互通。
第一種模式,
話語的交男的轉移,
也就是將密太交男從一個語
轉移導出到另外一個語。
密太交男能夠話語導出的前提,
使他得到了該交男的
原始數據提供方的授權。
為了能夠使得交男
導出到另外一個語,
需要將交男進行示範的分磚,
把它轉化成
另外一個語可以導入的通用的交男的格式,
之後再進行相關的交男的話語傳輸,
並導入到目標語。
中間的互聯互通的第二種模式,
就是直接的話語的寫成之詞,
對密太交男的話語使用,
都會回到密太交男所屬的
原始目標語取建權,
驗證交男的使用控制策略,
相比之前的模式語,
它對權限控制更加徹底與統一。
下面我們討論一下密太交男的關鍵過程,
完整的密太交男處理過程,
可能包括密太交男的分裝,
密太交男的註冊,
密太交男的加工處理,
原生交男的產生與再加工,
交男數據等,
密文導入等。
原始數據提供翻將密文數據
分裝成密太交男,
並施加對應的交男的策略,
之後將密太交男註冊,
並可以根據需要管理
添加交男的收搶規則,
後續其他機構想要申請
加工或者處理原始交男的數據,
並生成原生交男的數據,
後續其他機構申請對
原始密太交男的數據,
或原生的密太交男的數據
進行加工或處理,
都會受到原始數據提供翻
提供的策略規則的約束。
舉個例子,
如果需要設立到將
原生的密太交男的數據
密文導出,
它同樣也會受到
原始數據提供翻的策略控制,
需要受到原始數據
提供翻的資格。
通過本課程,
我們了解到了
密太交男的概念,
組成以及他與密太機上可信,
空間數字合約的關係等,
之後我們介紹了
密太交男的車售,
全線模型款,
發空間的互聯互通等,
最後我們介紹了
密太交男的關鍵過程,
都會對密太交男的技術
識別有感興趣的後續
歡迎繼續關注我們的社區,
我們會有陸續的開展。